[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Welcome, everyone.
We are here at the Dev Zone at
the Pizza Authenticator app.
Terry, tell me, what
am I looking at here?
I was promised pie.
All I see is pizza.
What's going on?
TERRY RYAN: It is a
form of pie, right?
So we have an app here that
will authenticate pizza
to a certain region
of the country, right?
Like, we have New York
pizza, California pizza,
Chicago pizza.
This app will
judge how authentic
it is for what style
it's supposed to be.
RETO MEIER: OK, interesting.
So why don't you--
actually, why don't you
show us how it works?
TERRY RYAN: So we
have our pizza here,
and we have our tablet here.
RETO MEIER: Fantastic.
TERRY RYAN: Make sure
it's in focus, and bam.
And now Pizza Authenticator
is judging whether or not
this pizza is authentic.
So it's chewing on it.
And we see that it is
pretty confident that this
is New York style pizza.
RETO MEIER: So definitely
pizza, probably from New York.
TERRY RYAN: OK.
RETO MEIER: OK, let's
check out this over here.
That's a good looking pie.
TERRY RYAN: This
is more Midwest.
So let's see.
Make sure it's in focus,
and we'll do it again.
She's taking a bite out of that.
Chicago style pizza.
RETO MEIER: Chicago style--
all right.
TERRY RYAN: That's good, right?
Now we'll finish up, and
we'll do this last one.
RETO MEIER: Yeah,
let's do the last one,
because I'm curious to what
style pizza this thinks it is.
TERRY RYAN: I think it knows.
I think it knows what it is.
RETO MEIER: I can't think
of any pie that deserves
to have zucchini on it.
TERRY RYAN: Yep.
Well, here in the
wonderful Golden State,
we make abominations.
Yes, California-- yes, so it
knew it was California pizza.
RETO MEIER: Excellent.
Well, I mean, I'm a huge
supporter of anything that
involves this amount of pizza.
But tell me, what is
the point of this?
Like, why is this
in the Dev Zone?
Why have we got this?
Yeah.
TERRY RYAN: So this uses
under-the-covers ML, right,
machine learning.
And ML is really daunting.
A lot of people
come to it, and they
think they need to be, like,
a data scientist to do it.
And your rank-and-file
developer sometimes, you know,
can't approach it.
Well, we took kind of an
incredibly trivial use of ML
and trained it to
determine whether or not
pizza was authentic.
And all of this we did.
We grabbed the data, we
classified all the images.
It was all done by me, who is an
app dev, not a data scientist.
RETO MEIER: Right, right.
TERRY RYAN: So it really
shows that anyone can do ML.
If I can do it,
anyone can do it.
RETO MEIER: So you could take
the same sort of technology,
the same approach
here, and really
apply it to much more
meaningful projects.
TERRY RYAN: Right, if you wanted
to take pictures, satellite
pictures, of forests and see
how they change over time
and see-- you could
identify trees
from the forest for
the trees, right?
You could do that with this.
And that's a much more
serious application of this.
But it's the same principle--
pizza on to forests.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
No, and it's a fun way to
approach machine learning,
that sort of stuff.
Fantastic.
[MUSIC PLAYING]